welcome to this video playing only X
from Turkey let's see I recently have
lost games against the sky that I
remember some of them ended in those
warm up games that I had a play yeah
benoni and let's see what he's doing in
still store transposed to this modern
benoni or it's not a Molly benoni after
i took with the porn I don't it cannot
allow him to take my bishop yeah yeah
this is I'm always some always amazed
people play this kind of sacrifices all
the time and they're in most cases
simply not working at all does this is
simply not working but ok maybe in a
blitz game you can afford all kinds of
nonsense and get away with it but it
could also play a three and why didn't I
play a three after a three-year he
basically resides a 3 was much stronger
yeah even if the opponent is playing
nonsense you should really look at it
and played the best possible refutation
a 3 was just much better ok yeah anyway
it says it's just a pawn for for pretty
much nothing you can try weird stuff
like taking on d5 taking on be too
but it's not really really working
yeah he needs to do something drastic
though I mean how you cannot really a
play and in all the moves okay so create
a five threatening discoveries if a
castle and takes on b5 if I need to take
with the sea party can take on d5 and
this isn't so clear even so is there a
way to to how to actually keep the
material now
castles Bishop b5 cb5 night XD for
iphone this isn't so clear
yeah okay what what what what else need
to do that I cannot do so I didn't see
anything any other move flood canceling
maybe Bishop b5 see takes b5 night f
takes d5 just bishop see one threatening
we should be for its maybe maybe a good
way to play I didn't see that one but
let's just just to play in the same
manner g6 still here
who came
queen bee 694 Quincy five what a lucky
position
hmm
94 hmm yeah thought Quincy seven but
maybe this isn't really really on never
I can play it I can play that twin c5
rook c8 looked looked a bit bad didn't
they didn't see where than to put the
Queen can play night see one Roxy one
Bishop b2 Brooke taxi five but that that
should be okay for white I mean better
white because the light is a bit
stranded yeah that's a it's a very very
difficult position of course I have
specially for maybe
yeah let's let's take that one at the
bottom so the ship should be three
Bishop f4 95 the specialty six
yeah I can take be too but I need to
activate pieces i cannot cannot stay
passive here
it takes with the bishop at age 60 this
wasn't really working complicated very
complicated 95 and a very hard to
calculate this with limited time
protecting the pawn ideas Bishop d3 to
see phone try to aim this Bishop
Arkansas in better directly going on f7
that's nice for right now the look and
the bishop only two really a powerful
some
yeah maybe I can operate with taking
okay
this is not working
time warning
Jeff that's getting a bit frustrating
against the sky he's very much lost in
every game and I lose it at the end
because it plays really well all of this
really bad positions
check yeah okay I can resign him white
yeah what a shame yeah of course I was
played that mean this position must be
good for white no doubt Bishop c5 young
bishops if I could be half before yeah
Bishop c5 was good but I just I just
didn't calculate well him okay losing is
really a disgrace I mean but yeah I
played this really well no I mean I
played it very badly but he took a good
use of that young yes here's the point
this is the kind of end game where every
move counts and here this Bishop c5 I
didn't I saw that but i thought i'm here
i'm in a self pin and like if he moves
the night i thought i'm in a self in but
it doesn't really it is not really a
problem i can i can take his heaven he
doesn't have a square to go to even this
year i can i can give check it's it's
it's not it's not a problem that this
pin now I needed to to calculate the
Sirkar ectly him after not doing that it
almost evaporates you know okay here i
can i can approach with the king and
song I mean it took it took many
mistakes from my part to lose it to good
use of it right here it's gone the deep
one just promotes alright thanks for
watching well no not-not-not doctor
quickly I just need to quickly look at
this would be five as such such but the
computer actually says this is the play
will move I don't believe it what
on a three Queen a five so what is this
guy doing here like before it looks like
what utter nonsense this move and it is
actually ok is this a book line or
something I mean no one really plays
this in four seconds unless you're a boy
hell no and that's your following an
online it really looks like completely
nonsense I mean a three I thought this
would just win basically what he's got
Queenie five and this isn't clear I mean
okay that's it it's I cannot take the
night then the bishop the night can take
it so this isn't completely unclear this
position and the way it played in the
game um blackest and in good shape maybe
this is a book lined I don't know it I
thought basically that in the game it
was clear that he had some play but I
thought a three what reviewed it but
he's got Queen a five you know maybe
this is a line when I don't I simply
don't I don't know it yeah I need to
look that up I mean this is really
amazing this is kind of move b5 it's
actually actually the move that the
computer recommends which is a bit bit
strange I know it's not a bit strange i
mean it i think it's strange that he
plays it in four seconds maybe it's a
it's really a book line I don't know
thanks for watching